GILLIAN.
>> PETER DOOCY FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL WALTZ A
FLORIDA.
A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
IT IS TEMPTING TO FOCUS IN ALL
THIS ON HOW THIS COMBUSTIBLE
ECONOMIC PICTURE WILL PLAY OUT
IN THE MID-TERMS.
THE MORE IMPORTANT THING TO
DRILL DOWN ON YOU FIRST HERE IS
HOW THIS IS PLAYING OUT IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE'S DAILY LIVES
NOW MANY MONTHS INTO THIS
INFLATION CRISIS?
I KNOW THAT IN PART AMERICANS
ARE IN THE WAKE OF A STORM
WITHOUT BASIC ELECTRICITY
SERVICE.
>> BIDEN'S REACHING OUT TO
DICTATORSHIPS, VENEZUELA, IRAN
WITH 50 MILLION BARRELS THEY ARE
TRYING TO SELL AS PART OF THE
IRAN DEAL, AND OTHERS JUST ISN'T
WORKING.
NOW WE HAVE   OPEC RESTRICTING
SUPPLY.
WHAT'S FRUSTRATING IS RIGHT HERE
UNDER THE GROUND IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA WE HAVE OIL
AND CLEANER GAS THAN RUSSIAN GAS
OR OTHERS READY TO GO.
NOT ONLY WOULD IT HELP AMERICANS
AT THE PUMP, BUT IT IS THE
BIGGEST DRIVER OF INFLATION
BECAUSE EVERYTHING HAS TO BE
TRANSPORTED.
BUT THE OTHER PIECE IS ON
FOREIGN POLICY.
RUSSIA HAS INVADED, PUTIN HAS
INVADED ITS NEIGHBORS EVERY TIME
IT WAS CASH FLUSH BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH PRICE OF OIL.
IN 2008 WITH GEORGIA AND 14 WITH
UKRAINE AND AGAIN THIS YEAR WHEN
OIL WAS OVER $100 A BARREL.
BIDEN COULD STARVE PUTIN'S WAR
MACHINE RIGHT NOW BY UNLEASHING
OIL AND GAS AND THEY KEEP
TELLING THE FICTION THAT
DOMESTIC OIL AND GAS COMPANIES,
THEY POINT TO THESE LEASES THAT
THEY ARE SUPPOSEDLY NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF.
IT IS BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION
ISN'T GIVING THE PERMITS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEM.
SO IT IS MISLEADING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND HURTING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IN THEIR WALLET AND IT IS
KEEPING PUTIN CASH FLUSH SO HE
CAN CONTINUE THIS INVASION.
>> THE SEARCH FOR SURVIVORS IS
STILL ONGOING.
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE VICTIMS
ARE IN FLORIDA THAT HAVE BEEN
DECIMATED.
AS THE STATE IS LOOKING TO
REBUILD THE GOVERNOR IS RINGING
ALARM BELLS ABOUT A WHOLE NEW
CHALLENGE.
>> WE HAVE HAD FOUR LOOTERS THAT
WERE ARRESTED.
I GUESS A COUPLE DAYS AGO.
THEY NEED TO BE BROUGHT TO
JUSTICE AND WE WON'T TOLERATE
IT.
BUT YOU KNOW, THREE OF THE FOUR
ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THEY ARE ILLEGALLY IN OUR
COUNTRY AND NOT ONLY THAT, THEY
TRIED TO LOOT AND RANSACK IN THE
AFTER MATH OF A NATURAL
DISASTER.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SLATED TO
MEET WITH THE GOVERNOR LATER
THIS AFTERNOON.
THE TWO SETTING ASIDE THEIR
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES OVER THE
PAST WEEK TO KICK START THE
MUCH-NEEDED RELIEF EFFORT.
CONGRESSMAN, MY QUESTION IS
THERE AN AFFECT OR AMERICAN LIFE
NOW THAT IS NOT TOUCHED BY THE
BORDER CRISIS?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I THINK WE WOULD STRUGGLE TO
FIND ONE.
WHEN I REACH OUT TO VETERANS WHO
AREN'T GETTING THE SERVICES THEY
NEED, TEACHERS WHOSE SCHOOLS ARE
ALREADY CROWDED, HOSPITALS THAT
CAN'T PROVIDE ALL THE SERVICES
THAT THEY WANT TO, THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY COST TO AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHEN WE HAVE 2 MILLION
PEOPLE A YEAR.
THAT'S NOT EVEN COUNTING THE
GOTAWAYS, THAT ARE FLOWING
ACROSS OUR BORDER.
THAT'S 8 MILLION PEOPLE JUST ON
BIDEN'S FIRST TERM THAT ARE
TAKING SERVICES THAT OTHERS MAY
NEED AND THAT AREN'T
APPROPRIATELY GETTING.
THERE ABSOLUTELY IS A COST IN
EVERY ASPECT OF LIFE.
I DO APPRECIATE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GIVING THE MAJOR
DISASTER DECLARATION TO THE
COUNTIES THAT NEED IT.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A LOT OF
FOLLOW-UP.
IT WILL BE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE FOR OUR CROPS.
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION FOR
THE INFRAY STRUCTURE.
A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO RECOVER
FROM THE STORM.
I EXPECT BOTH OF THEM WILL SET
DIFFERENCES ASIDE LIKE THEY DID
AFTER THE SURFSIDE CONDO
COLLAPSE A FEW YEARS AGO.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY AND FEMA ADMINISTRATOR
HAVE BOTH TRIED TO CLARIFY AND
DEFEND THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
COMMENTS ABOUT HURRICANE RELIEF
BEING BASED ON EQUITY AT LEAST
UNDER THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH.
NOW TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY
SAYS THIS.
>> WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE HELP
EVERYBODY BASED ON THE NEED THAT
IS THERE, THAT IT'S FAIR AND
EQUITABLE AND THERE ARE SOME
FOLKS WHO SEE POLITICS WHERE IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE.
IN THE END I THINK YOU DO NEED
TO HELP EVERYBODY BASED ON THEIR
NEED.
NOW, IF YOU ARE A VACATION HOME
GOT DAMAGED THAT'S HAVING A
DIFFERENT AFFECT ON YOUR LIFE
THAN IF YOUR ONLY HOME GOT
DAMAGED.
>> A "WASHINGTON EXAMINER"
OPINION PIECE OUT TODAY ARGUES
THIS.
KAMALA HARRIS'S PREJUDICE COULD
DISSUADE PEOPLE FROM SEEKING
NEEDED HURRICANE AID.
FIRST OF ALL, DO YOU AGREE WITH
THAT?
SECOND OF ALL, IS THERE ROOM FOR
ADDRESSING THE NEEDYEST AND
INCLUDING EQUITY IN THE WAY YOU
ROLL OUT THESE FUNDS OR DO WE
HAVE TO CHOOSE?
>> THAT'S THE WHOLE PROBLEM WITH
VIEWING THE WORLD THROUGH THE
LENS OF RACE OR THROUGH THE LENS
OF PEOPLE'S SKIN COLOR.
NUMBER ONE, THIS IS NOT THE
TIME.
WE ARE ALL COMING TOGETHER AS
AMERICANS IN OUR COMMUNITIES, AS
NEIGHBORS, AND WE'RE HELPING
EACH OTHER OUT AS FELLOW
CITIZENS, PERIOD.
THAT REALLY SHOULD BE THE EXTENT
OF IT.
AND THERE ARE RULES IN PLACE,
FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU ARE APPLYING
FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF AID AND YOU
ARE DEMONSTRATING AN ADDITIONAL
NEED OR YOU DIDN'T HAVE
INSURANCE, THEN THOSE RULES ARE
IN PLACE AND THAT WILL BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT.
I THINK THIS IS VIRTUE SIGNALING
AT ITS WORST AND IT IS BLOWING
BACK ON THEM BECAUSE IT IS JUST
EXPOSING THE WRONG-HEADED VIEW
OF THE WORLD THAT THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT KEEPS PUTTING
FORWARD WHETHER IN OUR MILITARY
OR WHETHER IT'S HOW WE HELP
PEOPLE IN THE WAKE OF A
DISASTER.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET
INTO THIS REAL QUICK.
YOUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES IN
THE HOUSE ARE VOWING TO
INVESTIGATE HUNTER BIDEN'S
FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS
FURTHER IF THEY TAKE CONTROL OF
CONGRESS IN NOVEMBER.
THREE STILL UNEARTHING NEW
TEXTS, EMAILS AND EVIDENCE THE
PRESIDENT'S SON CAPITALIZED ON
HIS FATHER'S POSITION WHEN HE
WAS V.P.
NOW HIS FORMER BUSINESS PARTNER
IS COMING FORWARD AGAIN.
HE TALKED TO TUCKER CARLSON.
>> SUBSEQUENT TO THE ELECTION HE
IS SITTING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BUT THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF DATA POINTS THAT JOE
BIDEN WAS ACTING IN A
CAPITALISTIC TERM.
HE SHOWS UP AT MEETINGS, SHAKES
HANDS, ADVISES, HAS FAITH IN HIS
TEAM.
EFFECTIVELY THAT WAS JOE BIDEN'S
ROLE IN THE BIDEN FAMILY
BUSINESS VENTURES AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
NOT JUST MY VENTURE.
THAT WAS A MULTIPLE TIMES.
>> THAT'S WHAT BOBULINSKI SAYS.
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT BACK IN
2020 ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, HOW MANY
TIMES HAVE YOU EVER SPOKEN TO
YOUR SON ABOUT HIS OVERSEAS
BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> President Biden: I HAVE NEVER
SPOKEN TO MY SON ABOUT HIS
OVERSEAS BUSINESS DEALINGS.
I HAVE NEVER DISCUSSED WITH MY
SON OR MY BROTHER OR ANY ONE
ELSE ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH
THEIR BUSINESS.
>> DO YOU STANDEE BY YOUR
STATEMENT YOU DID NOT DISCUSS
ANY OF YOUR SON'S OVERSEAS
BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> YES, I STAND BY THAT
STATEMENT.
>> I SHOULD POINT OUT BOBULINSKI
LAST NIGHT, WHETHER YOU FIND HIM
CREDIBLE OR NOT, SIR, SAID THAT
JIM AND HUNTER BIDEN STOOD TO
PROFIT TO THE TUNE OF NOT
MILLIONS, NOT TENS OF MILLIONS
BUT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF ALL THIS?
>> THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
HAVE A THEORY.
THEY HAVE A DOCTRINE THAT'S
CALLED ELITE CAPTURE.
THAT IS TO CAPTURE AND BASICALLY
CORRUPT KEY ELEMENTS OF AN
ADVERSARY'S SOCIETY.
WHEN IT COMES TO MAJOR POLITICAL
FIGURES, THEY GO AFTER THE SONS,
NOT THE PRINCIPLE.
THE PRINCELINGS.
THAT FALLS IN LINE WITH THAT
THEORY FROM THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
HE IS A HOLDER OF A COMPANY THAT
THE BLACK LISTED TRYING TO STEAL
AMERICAN WAR HEAD TECHNOLOGY.
SO MANY THINGS WE NEED TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF.
THE THING THAT'S DISTURBING IS
THAT THE F.B.I. DID NOTHING
ABOUT IT.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE A
NON-INTERFERENCE POLICY IN THE
RUN-UP TO AN ELECTION.
DOING NOTHING IS ALSO POLITICAL
INTERFERENCE AND THEY'VE DONE
NOTHING FROM THEN UNTIL NOW IS
FURTHER ERODING OUR TRUST IN THE
F.B.I. AND THE D.O.J.
>> WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT THERE.
THANKS FOR TAKING TIME OUT FOR
US THIS MORNING AND WISH YOU THE
BEST GOING FORWARD W